bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur r2
france pas de remontées mécaniques donc
lors des vacances de février comment est
ce que vous avez accueilli cette
nouvelle est ce que vous vous y
attendiez
écoutez il avait déjà annoncé le 20
janvier quand on a vu les annonces de
jean-baptiste lemoyne donc ce n'est
malheureusement pas une surprise c'est
toujours une grande tristesse pour nous
parce que nous rêvions de pouvoir faire
de travail et de pouvoir générer de
l'activité sur nos territoires mais si
on nous avait annoncé seulement là une
réouverture pour les vacances sont était
bien trop tard malheureusement pour
pouvoir remplir et avoir des clients
pour faire nos activités normalement
alors justement les vacances de février
débute à la fin de la semaine
comment s'annonce cette période qui est
primordial bhl primordial pour votre
chiffre d'affaires est ce que votre
carnet de réservations se remplit malgré
la fermeture des remontées mécaniques en
étant exploitants des remontées
mécaniques je devrais me dire que nous
traçons sera fermée donc l'activité sera
équivalente à 0 malheureusement ou très
faible verrière qu'il public dérogatoire
mais nous voyons bien que
malheureusement les carnets de
réservations pour le reste des acteurs
de la station n'est pas au beau fixe
parce que quand on enlève le ski sur nos
territoires qui est le moteur économique
du territoire et ben l'activité
malheureusement faibli grandement et
c'est bien triste parce qu'on aurait pu
en avaient toutes les conditions pour
faire de très belles vacances s'est
relancé la dynamique économique de nos
stations les aides compensatoires vont
être renforcés pour le secteur de la
montagne elle pourrait atteindre 7
milliards d'euros au lieu de quatre
actuellement d'après le gouvernement
concrètement quels types dead attendez
vous quel type des navets vous peut-être
déjà reçu nous aujourd'hui pour les
exploitants des remontées mécaniques et
des pistes nous attendons toujours la
validation de la commission européenne
sur le fond dette qu'on avait négocié au
mois de décembre pour la première
période et que nous allons étaler sur
toute la saison mais ce ne sera pas
suffisant et nous devons trouver des
solutions pour nos collaborateurs pour
l'activité partielle
nous avons eu l'information hier que
nous pourrions les prolonger jusqu'au 15
janvier en activité partielle mais nous
voyons beaucoup de trous dans la
raquette pour les commerçants avec une
non prise en charge a juste proportion
de leurs charges fixes et de la même
chose pour les résidences de tourisme et
les clubs de vacances qui sont nos
possibilités de remplir pour les années
futures dont une devant laissé tomber
personne parce que nous devons
sept sur la ligne de départ l'année
prochaine pour relancer et permettre à
nos territoires de continuer à vivre
économiquement et socialement pour vous
cette saison de ski cette année est
définitivement très compliqué elle est
très compliqué on ne connaît pas
l'avenir on voit bien qu'en fonction de
l'évolution de la pandémie et des
variants nous sommes soumis entre
guillemets à des décisions que nous ne
maîtrisons pas et notre avenir est
malheureusement tendre entre nos mains
et ça c'est très difficile de devoir se
rendre compte que malgré nos efforts
malgré tout ce que l'on peut mettre en
place nous ne sommes pas maîtres de la
situation
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne alexandre
rolland président de domaines skiables
en france